and the Cargill residents were treated
to a more in depth locket and the COG
whose rugby stadium on Sunday the 17th
of May for its first open day since its
change of ownership the end Vacarro City
Council voted to take ownership of the
venue in February Invercargill venue &
Events Manager Kate fever said the icc
used its first open day to give the
city's residents a chance to get a
better feel for the venue those who took
up the ICC's invitation braved the
elements to get a first-hand look at
behind the scenes of the stadium the
curious residents were given the chance
to voice their opinions suggest how they
would like to see the stadium used in
the future and have some questions
answered about the venue venue and
events management staff were on hand
throughout the event to give direction
and assist with questions from the
public as well as giving tours of the
corporate boxes lounges the main stand
the Stags changing rooms and other
facilities the venue had to offer